a lot of people know Google for its
search tools and software like Android
but did you know that Google also
develops its own dedicated Hardware
Google makes its own chips no not the
potato ones but computer chips that we
use in our machine learning
supercomputers pixel phones Network
infrastructure and even in YouTube as
the video accelerators that uploaded
this video were designed and created
in-house at Google all these chips from
servers to super computers rely on
Google Cloud if you're interested in
learning more about Google Cloud visit
cloud.google.com make make sure to click
the like button if you enjoyed the video
and the Subscribe button to watch more
content like this